au seuil de la camargue et du languedoc
le domaine de la grande motte constitue
la charnière de cette nouvelle floride
que l'état veut faire surgir démarré
qu'à début des années 60 la grande motte
à 25 km de montpellier est encore un
lieu désert un endroit idéal pour lancer
la mission racine un projet
d'aménagement du littoral du
languedoc-roussillon pauvreté par le
gouvernement du général de gaulle est
bien dans une civilisation où la part
des loisirs ne cessera de croître
il est normal que l'état recherche des
lieux encore vierge où puissent se
développer cette civilisation
l'intention est donné le développement
du tourisme de masse devient la priorité
de l'état
grâce à cette nouvelle station balnéaire
il espère aussi détourné les touristes
des destinations espagnoles de l'époque
il ne s'agit pas d'une station pour une
partie de la société commence alors dès
1965 un véritable défi urbanistique gras
grande motte était jusqu'ici une zone
sableuse et marécageuse impropre aux
constructions
le secteur est aussi en reste et de
moustiques dont il faut absolument se
débarrasser les commandos de
démoustication pratiquement chasser
l'ennemi de toutes les eaux qui
l'infestent et jadis plus de moustiques
en ces lieux il rendait inhabitables à
l'homme nouveau port nouvelle route
nouveaux ensembles urbains la station
balnéaire de la grande mode prend forme
sous le regard des habitants du coin
naval chargé la grille mais je crois que
j'ai quelque chose pour l'avenir qui est
qu'il faut savoir le projet pharaonique
de la grande motte est confiée à
l'architecte jean balladur pendant vingt
ans il repoussera les limites de la
création architecturale son empreinte la
voici des constructions pyramidale pour
démarquer la grande mode des autres
villes balnéaires
un choix qu'il expliquait en 1966 nous
avons établi des terrasse solarium en
très grand nombre qui donneront
précisément occupants de la station la
possibilité de jouir à plein d'un des
facteur d'attrait de cette de ce
littoral à savoir le serait cette audace
architecturale fera couler beaucoup
d'encre mais la modernité des
infrastructures subjugué tout de même
les premiers touristes au début des
années 70 on a écrit beaucoup de choses
sur la grande motte mal aussi fait très
bien longtemps qualifiée de ville béton
la grande motte a été labellisé en 2010
au patrimoine du xxème siècle la station
balnéaire accueille plus de 100000
estivants chaque annick
[Musique]